Speaker 1: . Hey, this is a really interesting
story.
There is a new report, CNN and others reporting
that Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner are now
distanced and maybe even estranged from former
President Donald Trump because of his complete
inability to move on from having lost the
20 20 election.
CNN reports.
With each passing day away from Washington,
former President Trump's grievances continue
unabated, and those complaints appear to be
driving away two of the people who were closest
to him during his White House tenure, his
daughter, Ivanka Trump, and his son in law,
Jared Kushner.
Going on to say a large part of the reason
for the separation is Trump's constant harping
on the past and his inability to move on,
the former president has also started to question
the role that Kushner, one of the few people
who were able to stay close to Trump throughout
his two presidential campaigns in White House
tenure has played in his presidential legacy.
Ivanka Trump has also struggled to undo the
entanglements caused by the years at her father's
side in the White House as she seeks a less
complicated life for her family, according
to two acquaintances.
That seems like a reference to the complete
disaster that was Ivanka and Jared trying
to reintegrate themselves into New York City
life and being shunned.
They described her as having to walk a fine
line between embracing her father and distancing
herself from the election lies one club goer
at Mar a Lago and family friend said they
weren't around for the usual spring and summer
events at Mar a Lago, noting the absence of
Trump's elder daughter and the couple's three
young children.
Simultaneously, the disappearance of Kushner,
once the ringleader of Trump's policy, was
also apparent.
A person familiar with Kushner says there
were visits from the Kushner Trump family
to Mar a Lago long before before Trump's move
north.
But they were sparse, averaging one every
three to four weeks.
The physical distance between them was not
far because Kushner and Ivanka were living
in Miami awaiting the construction of their
mansion on a nearby private island.
Kushner's presence physically and virtually
has become increasingly rare as it became
clear that his father in law remained preoccupied
with the twenty twenty election, according
to one person familiar with the situation.
This is not hugely surprising to me.
You know, it became clear in the late days
of the Trump administration that in particular,
Jared and Ivanka and especially Ivanka were
realizing that the reintegration was not going
to go super smoothly.
There were reports about their their being
shunned by the high society circles in which
they previously ran.
And this is not I don't I don't feel bad for
them.
I don't care.
They chose this.
Tiffany Trump, for example, stayed out of
the limelight.
And I'm aware of her having many left wing
friends and she sort of goes in different
circles and is not being shunned in the same
way.
Although her role at the Republican National
Convention was pretty disgusting, Don Junior
and Eric are fully bought in to continuing
the sycophantic brownnosing.
You see them regularly on Fox News and Newsmax
and on other programs.
So they've they've kind of staked out that
position in the aftermath of the Trump administration.
Ivanka and Jared and in particular Ivanka
have removed themselves from politics.
But they were so visible and so involved during
this administration that now people are saying
we don't we don't like you.
You know, before we accepted you and you were
less overtly political and at least you weren't
actively going around as Republicans.
Remember, Trump was a Democrat much of his
life.
So whether we like you or not, they were kind
of tolerated in these high society circles
in Manhattan and in Los Angeles, Miami, et
cetera.
But they're now, in a sense, tainted and Kushner
just disastrous participation.
Remember, they're our it's our stockpile.
It's not their stockpile, that entire thing.
He's doing masks.
He's doing swabs and all of this stuff.
It's become so humiliating and so embarrassing
that now they are having trouble reintegrating
into society.
That's their choice.
But the estrangement from Donald Trump is
very interesting.
And the political connection is is a very
narrow one, which will mention briefly one
question about Trump.
Twenty twenty four is what will Trump's health
be like then?
Second question about Trump.
Twenty twenty four is, will he still have
the bulk of the Republican Party behind him?
Third question, about twenty, twenty four
is will Trump's favorites win in twenty two.
And if they don't, does that hurt his chances?
But there's another question here, which is
if there is a Trump twenty twenty four run,
does he have the same coalition of his family
strongly supporting him?
Because four not not all.
But for many of these right wingers, particularly
the evangelicals, they had to be a lot.
Well, they almost they all were lied to.
But the evangelical specifically had to be
lied to about, oh, Trump's pro-life.
Now, he's been pro-choice his whole life.
Suddenly, six months before running for president,
he's he's pro-life.
The evangelicals had to be sold that bill
of goods.
And similarly, Trump as a family man with
his children all around him, even though the
cheating, the divorce, you know, all this
different stuff, it doesn't matter.
They were able to ignore it.
But the family unit around Trump was a big
piece for some of those evangelicals, along
with the lies about abortion and other things
in them ultimately coming around to him.
Without that, does Trump have the same cachet?
Some of these religious rightists, if the
family is not around him, I don't know the
answer to that question, but it's something
we will know before too long.